- Oh my gosh, it's an
honor to have you here.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you for coming
- Pleasure to having me.
(Yuh-jung laughs softly)
- Those lines could be used many times
and I will be stealing them.
Is it true that you
started acting by accident?
(Yuh-jung laughs softly)
- It is true.
- So, how does that happen?
- Well, it's a long story,
I will try to make it short.
Please understand my language.
I do have a lack of English.
- I'm understanding you perfectly.
- If you ask me a simple question,
I will answer it simply.
In Korea, if you graded
certain high school,
you got to go a certain level of college,
Ivy League college or something,
but I didn't get in.
(Yuh-jung laughs softly)
So, that's very disappointing
for my family and for my mother.
- Oh.
- So, I felt so sorry for my mother,
I tried to look for the part-time job,
but at that time back in 1960s,
my age is very old,
(Kelly laughs)
it was new, television was to Korea.
- Yeah.
I went to kind of tour
for the television station
and one guy,
I met him in hallway
and then, "Would you
like to have an audition?
Would you like to help us doing some kind
of presenting some gift for the audience?"
So I said, "Okay, I'll do it.",
and then I was freshman year
and they gave me the big check,
so, that was very tempting.
(Yuh-jung, Kelly and
audience all laughing)
- Yeah,
you were like, Wait,
so how many more times can I
present something to someone?
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's amazing that
that's how this all started.
And you are so gifted.
You are so talented.
That's amazing.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I just think it's amazing that
that wasn't your vocation
you were going for
and you just landed there.
So, is it true...
I found this out that a psychic told you
that you would find your
soulmate at 96-years-old.
(Yuh-jung laughs)
I have two things.
One, you gotta wait till
you're 96 to find this person?
And then two, congratulations.
(Yuh-jung laughs)
You're gonna make it to at least 96.
That's amazing.
(audience applauding)
- Actually. I asked him,
do you think I can recognize
he's real soul mate at age 96?
Maybe at age 96, maybe I
get Alzheimer or senile.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh my God.
- How can I recognize he's soul mate?
That was my question.
- That's amazing.
I just love that psychic.
Who tells someone that?
That's amazing.
So, wait, will you tell
us about your new show?
It seems so intense.
What is the new show about?
- Did you ever heard of Pachinko?
Wrote by a Korean-American also?
And it was, I think one time,
bestseller in New York times
or something like that.
- Yeah.
- It had a good review.
- I think all good shows were books, yeah.
- Apple bought this story
back in 1909 until 1989.
It's a four generation story,
of course I'm playing a grandma role,
so, it's no problem,
when I was young, the other actor,
a young actress plays my role.
In that time we were occupied by Japan,
so during that time they
happen to went to Japan
and they're struggling, suffering
in that foreign country.
That role was very...
Somehow I read the script
and it, really, immediate
connection with her.
- It spoke to you.
- Yes, yes.
Her strength and then her determination
to survive from foreign country,
for her it's a foreign country,
she was in Korea.
- Yeah.
- Born in Korea,
and then she happened to went to Japan.
So, I relate to her and that's
why I wanted to do this role.
So I just... I thought...
I'm not sure I did it okay but we'll see.
- You did awesome,
and I love the fact that you brought up,
we wouldn't be where we are,
we're so lucky from our ancestors
that paved the way
for us to have the life that we have.
(audience applauding)
- Indeed, indeed, indeed, yes.
- It's so important.
I think we forget,
a lot of us don't grow up with
that kind of family
around us, so we forget,
but God, how blessed we are
to have those people before us,
so that I could be here now.
- Yes, that's right.
That's right, yes.
(audience applauding)
- Well, Pachinko is
also a game at casinos,
I don't know if you gamble,
but have you ever been to Las Vegas?
Have you ever gambled?
- Yes, I've been there
because my dear friend is living there,
so, actually she took me to that.
Every place just has a machine.
- Slot machines.
- Yes, slot machines.
And then she said... She gave me $20
and then she asked me
to just push the button
or just pull it like this,
so I said to her, "It's not hygienic.",
because millions of
people have touched it.
- You're my sister,
my sister, I kid you not,
comes in with Lysol,
she wipes it down,
she's afraid of that too.
- Me too, no, I don't wanna do that.
(everyone laughs)
- Okay, so, thank you so much, Yuh-jung.
You can see Pachinko on Apple
TV plus starting tomorrow.